قبل كده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في البيت
العسكريين شغال
[موسيقى]
الهند
سيه
مقابل
المشكله الثانيه
انا
باكلم الحمار
مليحه
زي الموجود الانديه
التهرب
من ايطالي
ا
المناقشه الجديده بعد العيد مبسوطه بس
بس الحاجه
كده موضوع مؤسسه
النقطه كله طالعات شديد فقدت منه انا
عايز اعمل منه بلوشي
[موسيقى]
اوكي زور اليوم
اخذت معك منين من الكتب عشان هذه اسرع ما
يمكن حاسس كل حاجه انه
بدات لو كان اختصارطه
وجعلنا 24 ونرجع عن السياح طبعا
وكنت بانيت كل مره وباصلي فيها وكده
عشان نحس ان والدتك الانجليزيه وانت
بتستغي بموت في سياق الاجانب الفيديو
حيوان
بالصدفه
يا قلبي
الاثنين
وبعدين
يكلمك
من 1.600 الف متعبه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
جدا جدا
في الموضوع ده
انا المشروع الجاهز ده الاعمال
الاعمال
الاخوان
[موسيقى]
قاعدين في البيت
حجه
دروس دروس
[موسيقى]
البحث
الصوتي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حلوه
كل السيارات
حتى النفس اللي انت ممكن تكون موجود
القرار الذي ذكر
مصارعه انا عايز جميله
في جسم الانسان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]